proprio perché fare bravate ho mai
sentito berlino il campanello è arrivato
qualcuno
andiamo a vedere dai vieni con me dai
vediamo sì c'è nessuno
una maschera biglietto indossa mi
che strano kg breve spedirmi una
maschera dietro un po strana come
maschera
vabbè c'è scritto indossa mi magari la
prova
[Musica]
mi spaventa la scusa non volevo
spaventarti guarda qualcuno ci ha
inviato una maschera è bellissima è un
po strana fa un po paura eh sì però
scritto indossa mi ha detto non l'ha
indossata mi auguro non ancora ma vorrei
provarla e ovvio che ti scrivono
indossano eto'o non la deve indossare
dai è solo una maschera cosa vuoi che ti
faccia poiché ti mangi d'italia paura
della maschera c'è scritto in passato è
normale che uno non lo deve indossare no
e secondo quale logica e che ne so tu
sai che te la tata vostra maschera ma
penso che sia un regalo per halloween in
ritardo non lo so io non mi fiderei
comunque fa sei sempre il solito paolo
vabbè dai la lascio prova da dare da
mangiare a marino premunendosi neanche
martino allora ciao
non capisco perché la vita non mi prende
mai sul serio riguardo queste cose
merlino e tu che cosa ci fai qui perché
stava dando da mangiare l'unitá come mai
sei qui vicino alla maschera e tenuta
un'idea le farò uno scherzo per uno
scherzo ad anita indosserò questa
maschera e la farò spaventare anzi la
prova subito
[Musica]
e vitale tutto bene ho sentito un rumore
strano berlino mandato vitale per dinho
studentato vitale rivisto c'è un po di
buio qua
accendiamo una luce perline visto vitale
dove andate
che strano eppure vitale ra qua in
studio però berlino ma tu non l'hai
proprio visto poi tutto finita la
maschera c'era la maschera qua da
qualche parte forse ho capito vitale
siccome aveva paura di questa maschera
l'avrà presa e portata fuori o buttata o
portata in macchina da qualche parte
sicuramente va beh ma allora aspetterò
che torni
guardate ha lasciato quel biglietto
indossa mi strano che se lo è
dimenticato
mah vabbè tanto e solo un biglietto
c'è nessuno ti ho visto vitale sei tu
guarda che ti mettono dietro ma quello
di vitale vero avete visto anche fuori
stai giocando a nascondino tu l'hai
visto forse ma questo non solo immagina
altro mi ha impressionato talmente tanto
quella maschera che sta vendere le
situazioni merlino previsto qualcosa
anche marino è un po strano facendo hai
deciso di provare la maschera stile
svago ma è un po strano molto divertente
questo scherzo vitale ora puoi anche
toglierti e poi perché non parli rino
sai perché si sta comportando in modo
così strano vitale lo sai che a lui nel
passato si sa che gioco sta giocando
vitale qui ci state capendo qualcosa
e tu berlino anche tu sei un po strano
anche a tema ho fatto qualche strano
effetto la maschera
aspetterò che si riprenda tanto ora è
uscita è andato da qualche parte tanto
io me ne sto in cameretta tranquilla
finché è vitale non si riprende o la
smette di giocare o farmi gli scherzi
comunque c'è qualcosa di strano oggi
berlino e laggiù ha deciso di rimanere
sopra alla finestra vitale un po strano
2 riparatevi di lasciare un bel mi piace
su questo video dell'ultimo video qui
abbiamo costruito un parco giochi in
giardino per berlino è stata super
divertente perché merlino faceva il
percorso a ostacoli quindi se non lo
avete visto andate poi a vedere
che cosa vuoi vitale
ragazzi mi sono nascosta in camera da
letto c'è qualcosa che non va in meta le
non so perché sta indossando quella
maschera ma non sembra in se stesso
sempre che la maschera gli abbia fatto
qualcosa
vai via
[Musica]
mutu stato aprire la povertà
[Applauso]
se qualcosa poco dobbiamo fare qualcosa
devo assolutamente togliere quella
maschera dal passati vitale ho paura che
altrimenti non si riprenderà più
forse mi sta solo facendo uno scherzo
berlino smettila di aprire le porte fai
paura poi un po di silenzio mentre
erotiche quell'osso
[Musica]
ma no
nascosta dietro a pupazzi al piano di
sopra
non mi sembra che se ne sia accorto ora
potrei buttarli qualcosa in testa
[Musica]
s'è detto
beccati questo sarà così impari
no no non l'ha fatto niente premiamo
buttarli la bonanni testa non ha
funzionato
[Musica]
che cosa devo fare per mandarlo via
cazzi dobbiamo trovare un piano per
togliere la maschera a vitale quale può
essere molto debole di una maschera non
è un'idea secondo fai qualcosa s.marino
forse potresti aiutarmi tu che ne pensi
[Musica]
ma poi non capisco perché vitale
indossato la maschera se è stato lui
stesso a dire di non indossarla
assolutamente c'è qualcosa di strano
devo tirare qualcosa di duro in testa e
magari riuscirò a far svanire l'effetto
[Musica]
perché usare questa questa matita
gigante siccome lui ha la testa dura
gli tirano al matitone gigante nella
maschera speriamo che il matitone
funzioni secondo cui considera ora non
ci resta che scendere giù un cuore vai
via
poi mio zio avete sentito che erano
levati ancorato alla maschera e rino
marino
scendiamo l'acqua marino che succede
berlino sta togliendo la maschera bravo
berlino macro primissimo cosa è successo
[Musica]
festa maledettissimo maschera dobbiamo
buttare una via per sempre
ma che cosa è successo
ma come non ti ricordi niente stavo
prendendo la maschera qui l'ho cercato
di portare al riso come non ti ricordi
niente mi sembra molto strano
avevi l'amato cercavi di prendermi non
lo so cosa volevi fare non so se sia
stato uno scherzo o magari questa
maschera e maledette c'è qualcosa che
non va in ogni caso sbarazziamo cene ve
l'ho detto infatti che non bisogna mai
indossare le maschere che non sai da
dove vengo si è allora perché lei
indossata
berlino dimmi tu la verità è stato lui a
indossarla
e stato lui a indossarla di me lo
ringrazia che berlino non può parlare
dove possiamo sbarazzarci di questa
maschera
non lo so magari chiudiamola in una
scatola e poi un'idea mi ricordi la
scatola che non dovevamo aprire se si
trasformava berlino sarebbe stata la
fine
ti ricordi la scatola che non dovevamo
aprire ma poi abbiamo aperto la
chiediamo la dentro a il soffitto allora
non riderà sì e mi raccomando non
dobbiamo mai aprire quella scatola sì
concordo mai aprile anche berlino
d'accordo 20 sfruttando la zampa mi
raccomando dobbiamo fare tutti e tre un
patto mai andare in soffitta ad aprire
quella scatola ok che berlino bravissimo
a berlino promette ma anche evitare
berlino sale caso tutte le fabbriche
[Musica]